it's our last friday
did i hear an oh thank you for that one
oh
it's okay i'll take what i can get um
it's our last friday um and uh
and and so next week is our last week we
have class on monday and wednesday will
be the last class
um and we've got one more smallish topic
to cover after this
uh which is diffusion and we'll wrap up
on wednesday
um but today i want to keep talking
about polymers
so this is our polymer week and
i want to go back to the properties i
put here
the the properties we've talked about
right so
on monday we focused on what a polymer
is
and we focused on the ways you make it
right the the the radical initiation
chain addition and the condensation
polymers you know
the condensation right where you have
two different mers
and then on wednesday we talked about
things that matter right kind of like
engineering polymers like what are the
properties of of the polymers that
that you can change that we can change
right
and so we talked about you well you
could pick a different monomer
that'll change the properties right uh
we've been through that uh
you could try to grow longer or shorter
strands
all right so that that that's going to
change properties of the interactions
between
the strands which will of course depend
on
on what you pick there right
uh and then we talked about uh the
density and the crystallinity
and how that could depend on things like
cooling rate right
uh or maybe the physical structure
itself of the chain
so what do i mean by that well i mean
when i say physical structure of course
i mean the chemistry that makes that
physical structure so i could branch
the chain with the same monomers but now
instead of being one linear chain it's a
bunch of branches
or maybe you could you could have a
functional group that you can control
which side of the chain it's on and all
those things
would lead to differences in density and
crystallinity
and then the last thing we talked about
is cross-linking
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
add one more thing to this list today
but before i do that i want to pick up
on the last slide of wednesday which is
this
i so so we tend so all this kind of goes
in together
to give you these solids called polymers
right
yeah but we we talked about how they're
they're also you know sometimes they're
not fully solid
and that's what's going to come in the
middle but you can make a solid
thermal plastic which is these strands
right so what is the thermal huh what's
up
anyway so with thermoplastic we'll look
over here
there's no crosslinking so you don't
have any of this
but what do i have well i have these
really long strands
that are that are bonded together with
these imf's
typically in a thermal plastic
you would have something like maybe van
der waals right
and maybe you have some h-bonds
and these materials uh because you
didn't cross-link them
and and you didn't cross-link them
strongly right with some kind of strong
bond because of that
um you can reheat them and reprocess
them so these are actually
often the plastics that we recycle that
we can recycle
um and like i said they're mostly linear
and maybe slightly branched polymers
and they're used in a whole lot of
applications so we call them
thermoplastics
thermal you can heat them right you can
heat them
and you can see what happens is if i
heat these back up
right these links can start moving they
wiggle
and they wiggle and they wiggle and so
they can just kind of slide past each
other
right and and become a viscous uh
liquid and then a melt on the other hand
if i've got a thermoset thermal i heated
it up
and and then i as it set i cross-linked
it
and there are lots of ways you can
crosslink we talk about some of those
right
and now i've got a pretty high density
of cross legs so that's drawn here
so i've got these long strands remember
they're super super long right
and but now every so often uh
i i have something linking them together
and
if i put a lot of crosslinks in and if
they're strong crosslinks then you can
get
really hard plastics right and and so
these are hot the thermal set they're
set
they're set it's almost set good
it solidifies when and it can't be
reheated why
think about it if i heat that up right
then
okay i might melt the polymer so the
chains are kind of wiggling around but
those
those crosslinks aren't going anywhere
they're really strong
right and so what happens with thermal
sets is they're very difficult to
recycle
they're very difficult to recycle
because what will happen is before those
things melt
the whole thing catches fire the whole
thing catches fire
it burns often right or or maybe it
doesn't burn
but when you melt it you got this weird
chemistry now of of the crosslinker
mixed in to the polymer and it's not
useful anymore
so these kinds of plastic the crossing
gate is really great you make you know
like i said over 30
of all toys um it's used in many many
many applications these harder
plastics but they're not recyclable okay
and then talk about this intermediate
region
and this is where we end it we talk
about elastomers
and elastomers are in between right and
so
in an elastomer you've got light
crosslinking
and the crosslinking like in slime that
crosslinking has
a a weaker hydrogen bond
right and i remember we talked about how
that could lead to like viscoelasticity
really cool stuff um
in the you know in in other cases right
like in the case of the
the vulcanized rubber remember that
charles goodyear that story from
wednesday
in that case you put a covalent bond of
sulfur
between the strands right and that gave
you
a much stronger rubber that still had
some elasticity
right um but now the the best analogy
here
is still the spaghetti i keep coming
back to it i'm not letting go
think about it if i've got
a bowl of spaghetti and i pull on it
that's my plastic bag on the left right
that's my plastic wrap i pull on it and
those
those chains are all crumpled up and
tangled and i'm untangling them
and then i'm sliding them past each
other and pulling it until the whole
thing rips
that's the bowl of spaghetti but now
i've got the spaghetti that
attaches every so often one strand to
another
think about i've got a bowl of spaghetti
but in each strand of spaghetti
there's like five places where it's
attached to another strand of spaghetti
now what happens
i can pull that as well right i can pull
because
those spaghettis are all curled up and
so there's some
there's some amount of pulling that i
can do
while they uncurl until those links
take over and i can't pull past them
right
that's what the cross the light
cross-linking will do
and you say well if i had heavy
crosslinking in the spaghetti then the
whole
bowl of spaghetti wouldn't be very easy
to move because i'm always up against
all the links between them right
and so that's why these elastomers are
so interesting because
they thought well they're it's all
interesting but the elastomers fall in
between where
there's some of that uncurling of the
polymers until you get to a point where
depending on how much you cross-linked
and the bonding of the crosslink
you're going to go up against the
cross-linking right
and and so these are used so they're
free to move um now must be above its
glass transition temperature i want to
talk about that for a second
so i did mention this i want to be sure
that we all have a good sense of what
that means and so i wanted to you know
taking this
uh this elastomer say what happens when
you melt it
right and we drew this curve but i want
to
go very carefully this is the
temperature oh we love this curve
the molar volume right
and now up here you've got your liquid
right we know that and then
here is the place where it would
crystallize
can a polymer crystallized sure right if
a polymer crystallized then it would
just be these strands
in a crystal what is a crystal we know
it's it's a repeating ordered structure
yes
polymers can crystallize but as we've
talked about so
often what happens is you
because like you know like we talked
about with silica
they you know you got this very viscous
amorphous can't find the crystal sites
same with polymers and so you get a
glass
and then this was the tg now why am i
showing this because
with these strands i want to show you
you know we've drawn this before
where you know often what you get in
polymers is some degree
it's right here some degree of
crystallinity
right so so what do i do how do i do
this
well you've got you literally have both
right you literally so i've drawn this
already right so if i'm here
it on my polymer then it might look like
what i've drawn already on the board oh
i love doing this
and then there's the crystal and then
there's more
i've drawn this already right you've got
like this crystalline region so we've
got the crystal
and here because i'm below the glass
transition temperature
this part here is an amorphous oh boy
it's kind of small but this word says
amorphous
solid it's a solid
that part is a solid because it's below
the glass transition temperature
right okay but now let's start heating
this up
and as i get to the glass so now i'm
going to get here
and what happens is it doesn't actually
go
straight to the
the full liquid i mean it it it's got
this crystalline stuff in there
right it's got these regions this
crystal
has one melting point
remember the melting point of the
crystal is the melting point of the
crystal
it doesn't change glass transition
temperature can be can be tuned
but this is the melting now so what what
happens well what happens is there's
more of like a curviness to this and you
might kind of have
the shape look more like this
so what's happening this this just gets
a little bit more at the detail
of how a polymer would melt if it's got
any crystalline regions and as i've told
you
very often it does not always it could
have no crystalline regions
it could be totally amorphous but i've
drawn this enough that i wanted to
explain this curve
with that as our starting point right
and i've also talked about how the
degree of crystallinity is so important
for properties
and it can be controlled so what's
happening well in this region here
let's draw that picture so now i'm in
here and what happens is i'm below tm
but i'm above tg so that means
that literally in the same strand this
is so cool
that looks the same it's not supposed to
be the same
because now this is a liquid
this is a viscous liquid
and this is still a crystal
that's an extol
i'm below tm so the crystalline region
has not melted
but the rest of the polymer is above its
glass turns it is so
cool this one strand is both a solid and
a liquid
one strand that's so cool
that's in here all right and then i get
over here
and now here okay well
let's see so now this is all liquid and
the crystalline part is starting to come
apart
so crystal melts extol
melts right
well that sort of was supposed to be the
remnants of a crystal in there
and then above tm the whole thing's a
liquid right
so that's kind of zooming in i wanted to
make sure that we understood this plot
in the context of these polymers
and and that also gives you a sense now
okay now
that's this one strand now i've got a
bunch of strands
did i connect them or not and that adds
the layer of what an elastomer is
right because now you can imagine is it
is the elastomer
above or below tg where is tg are we
above or below tg when we bounce a ball
right how does that influence the
properties of the ball
the rubber ball is lightly crosslinked
right
and and you can imagine that if you're
below tg
then well all that all that amorphous
part of the ball
is is uh is a solid so there's an
elastic response
sure it could still bounce but if if
you're in this region then that
then that part of the ball is a liquid
but it's lightly crosslinked so the ball
doesn't fall apart
right so it's going to bounce
differently right
it's going to bounce differently okay so
anyway i wanted to just
go into detail that to make sure that we
feel our oneness and and i mean you
could add here
this is this is a you know because it's
so important
in just what it's like saying like just
in terms of what this
material how this material behaves you
could add the glass transition
temperature
which as we've already talked about has
a number of ways
that it can be tuned on the other hand
it may also
be tuned by some of these other things
that you do but it's a very important
part
of the polymer property ecosystem
okay good so that's the elastomer
that's the elastomer now there's one
more thing that we can do
that i wanted to talk about oh that's
the picture yeah i thought i'd show you
another
picture so i'm not the only one that
that draws things like this
right okay there's a nice one from
encyclopedia britannica and you can
imagine this region
being a solid down here then a liquid
but that's still solid and then that
that region melts all at once at tn
the last thing that i want to add is is
another way that we have to control
polymer properties and and it's uh
it's another bullet here and it'll be
our last one
and it's it's really the composition
and sequence
so what do i mean by that well
it turns out that you know
remember when we did condensation
right polymerization right a poly
condensation is called the condensation
polymerization
we had two different mers um and and we
could have picked the box remember the
box inside the merc could be different
things
um and then when we've done the radical
initiation we've just had one mer with a
double bond
right now if you have one mer then
that's called a homopolymer
um and if you homopoly
and if you have two it's called the
copolymer
and the thing is that we actually can
even we can make copolymers
with both approaches and not only that
but we're learning more and more how to
control
the sequence and that's what this shows
here
right so i could have a polymer a
you know let's say i have uh
yeah i'll put it below this let's say i
have a
you know polymer polyethylene p e
which is oh we know now how to draw
these c
c n
and then i've got the other one which is
pvc polyvinyl chloride
and that looks like this see all i've
done here is swap out
a hydrogen for chlorine and i've got a
totally different
polymer right some other
n okay and uh and an m whatever
i can now alternate these i can
alternate them
and i could alternate them in different
ways so p e might be my a
and p v c might be my b and if i
alternate them
we might you know if it's like regular
alternating we might write p
e this is how we'd write the copolymer a
pvc right but you could also have it be
random
so then you'd write p e you can take a
guess r pvc
right uh you could write a grafted
version
p e g well you get the point
pvc and so forth what i mean when i
write this
is that i've taken these two polymers
and i've co-polymerized
i mean sorry these two well yeah these
are the polymers the mod
i've taken the monomers and i've made
one polymer out of the two of them
but i've controlled the sequence it's
not now maybe it's not controlled
maybe it's random right there
or maybe i figured out how to do this in
a way
that i that i have the backbone all one
type
but i can have these side chains the
branches another type
that's really powerful it turns out or
maybe you can control that i have a
certain number of them
and then a certain number of the other
and this is called a block copolymer
a block copolymer some of you may have
heard of block copolymer chemistry
which is growing is a very growing very
powerful field because when you make
these blocks and you control
their properties you can imagine that
you control all sorts of things about
how that polymer
behaves imagine you make a
something that bonds to a but not b like
dissolves like right we've been there
b is something that bonds to b but not a
okay what's going to happen they're
stuck
but they're going to try to come
together and stay apart
in the same strand all sorts of
interesting things can happen it can be
engineered
when you can control these blocks
or these graphs right
so that's the last thing that we now
here's an example
this is uh i was trying to look for
again here's um something called
actually what is it called sirlin you
come up with that
i don't know why that's the name but
that's the name it's the serlin
resin which is the the ingredient that
goes into the polymer
okay and um
and look at what it does oh it provides
clarity toughness
versatility it's serlin is a leading
choice for food
cosmetic medical device skin
stretch packaging as well as golf balls
the tunability is enough why what is
serlin
well we don't know exactly because they
won't tell us but
sirlin is actually it's really cool it's
it's using
okay it's using uh where
where did i put it composition sequence
it's using sequence
to make a graft polymer where
you know one type is is is going along
the chain and the other type is coming
out
but really importantly the other type
is made specifically to form ionic bonds
so here b is made so that it can form
ionic bonds
with other parts ionic remember
that that's basically by grafting
right by creating a copolymer where one
type wants to form ionic bonds i've
crosslinked i've made a cross-link
built into the polymer itself the
cross-link is going to be
linking the strands together maybe
within itself maybe with other strands
but with an ionic bond
right but i've done it all without have
i've done it all just built into the
polymer
and that's why you can see here look at
this it's an
ethylene copolymer all right
so ethylene is the backbone the co is
what's coming out of the side and that's
an ionic bond so it's also called an
ionomer
what's an ionomer a polymer that has
ionic crosslinks
ionic bonded crosslinks and what's cool
about that well you get the whole world
of ionic bonding now in the mix
right and so and so what does that mean
well you could have it be very strong
golf ball you can have it be thermally
responsive
right you can tune at what temperature
these bonds break
there's all sorts of flexibility and you
can see it right here and how they're
marketing it
yeah can do almost anything
another example of the copolymer
i'll give you a couple examples of
copolymers this is one that
um that uh that you may have
seen maybe many of you experienced you
just don't remember
this is the diaper right and and so
so what um so what a diaper is
is it's got this this copolymer
made out of acrylic acid these are the
monomers
right notice the double bonds oh
we're going to take advantage of those
right and we're going to make a polymer
and we're but we're going to do it
in a controllable way so we're going to
take these tumors and we're going to
control how they come together
and very importantly in these kinds of
materials they're broadly
called you call them hydrogels right
these are materials that can absorb
hundreds of times by weight hundreds of
times
water into them why because in one of
the
copolymers in one of them you've got
this sodium atom
and what happens is there's the dry
state it's all curled up and
and and the chains want to be all
together but as soon as you introduce
water those sodiums like
going into the water and what happens
they leave behind this oxygen
that really wants the water right
because it's a negative charge and so so
you get a sodium ion going in solution
you get the solution coming to
the anion and even more than that
now if the sodium leaves then
what happens well what happens is all
those negative charges are left
and they repel each other that's going
to help this whole thing want to expand
right so that so that's that's a that's
uh
that's a diaper two percent of all
landfill by the way
now um so that's another example of a
cold polymer
uh and a really interesting way of
tuning the properties and here's
you know it has to do with you know what
what did we do we tuned the ionic
character of the backbone we tuned the
charge
right we made it responsive in terms of
its charge
to something in this case water the
presence of water that's cool
okay last one and and here i want to
talk about mechanical
strength so this is uh
uh uh this is the the tensile strength
so
how far could you pull this thing right
this material
um before it breaks and then here's the
elongation
right until it breaks so it gives you
now the tensile strength this is how far
can you pull it
in the elastic regime you can see that
for steel it's really high
but you can't pull it very far before it
breaks we know that right so steel's
really strong
but it's not very flexible there's nylon
we did nylon
so it's it's kind of not nearly as
strong but it has a lot of elongation
there's fiberglass this is plastic
reinforced glass
right where you can get a lot of
strength
very little flexibility more than steel
a little bit more than steel well
actually
a lot more but still it's only three or
four percent uh elongation
and here's a cellophane that's a
naturally can be a naturally occurring
um polymer you can also make it
synthetically in the in the mix and i
want to point out nitrile
nitrile rubber is a really interesting
copolymer
and and many of you may have seen or you
if you're in a lab you might use
nitrile rubber gloves you might have
them at home at the sink um
and one of the advantages of nitrile
rubber is again this enormous tunability
by just picking how you co-polymerized
how much of one
did you put in the other and and this is
uh
maybe i'll use this board here because
it's a really cool
copolymer where you're putting in
acetone acryla nitrile so here's what
this looks like
so you put your c h2
your ch your double bond your ch
your ch2 and there it is
and that's going to repeat some number
of units that you control
because it's a it's a block copolymer
before you put this one in and here's
the kick
it's got a triple bond nitrogen on it
and that's going to go a certain m
right now that that comes from acrylic
nitrile and butadiene but again it's the
synthesis to make the copolymer
it's the sequence yeah that keep on
forgetting where
it's up there it's the composition the
architecture
right is it how did i put those copies
if you do this in the right way it's the
amount of the acrylic nitrile that you
put in
will control the strength it'll make it
stronger and stronger and stronger
because you gotta you got this really
nice strong bond in here
and this will give the material a lot of
strength so that's why you can go up to
you know fairly reasonable but then how
much of this
i put in is going to determine how far
you can stretch it and so you balance
those
and you can make a whole bunch of kinds
of nitrile rubber
okay so i hope this is giving you some
some examples of
the tunability of polymers and
you know if you take the bigger picture
and this is a little hard to read and
you know it'll be on the slide so you
can look up this paper here
it was published in science a few years
ago and you look at the fracture
toughness with the yield strength
right so what is that well yield
strength is remember yeah we know that
because it's when you
you're in the elastic region and you're
pulling and then you yield to plastic
deformation
right that's the yield strength that
yield what about fracture toughness
well that's if you start a crack does
the thing tend to crack more or not
that's the fracture toughness basically
right and so you can put materials down
on this plot you got ceramics you got
concrete down here you got
right so um so you're not going to be so
so
the polymers sit here all right here's
the metals and alloys metallica
you can you can look at this on your own
and look at each one of those but i just
want to point out
polymers have a fairly wide range but
there's so much interest in
going beyond and there's a lot of
interest in
in using polymers in many other
applications we can't get there yet
because we can't
push it out here right or maybe out here
right we still need to figure out how to
tune it
more we got all these ways to control
the properties and we're still
only at the very beginning of
understanding how to engineer
polymers now
there is no better way to make that
point clear than to look at nature
right and and i already showed you the
tree and and the the you know the
examples of nature as a polymer engineer
i want to talk about that a little more
because nature is nature's not just a
polymer engineer
nature i'm going to write this down
nature
is a polymer engineer gone wild
and i'll show you why polymer engineer
humans what can humans do
i mean well we are a natural polymer
engineer
engineer material but what can we make
with all of what i've just shown you
what can we make
i can put like one or maybe
two or if you really go into the
research you get three
mers controlling trying to control where
they are in the chain
all right you got three maybe two we
really two most materials
cold polymer we're so proud of this
nitrile co two
mers and we control them and we make
rubber sheets
right but nature
but then they're everywhere they're
everywhere is just
that right so nature can have
so humans
have the same same
functional functional group
every stop all right okay that's like
one more maybe i've got two
maybe two or three nature
can have different different
groups and here's the key it can have
them everywhere
okay so
what i have is i have
many many many more possibilities
but i mean we have these possibilities
too we just can't control it
right so so if i look at like let's go
back to condensation
polymerization because this is what
nature does
right so this was what i drew for you on
on monday
there's a dicarboxylic acid right here
we're making nylon
and a diamine and we're making polyamide
and remember the box in nylon six six
the boxes six carbon
atoms i call that boring what's it six
carbon atoms
some hydrogen but that's kind of boring
but in nature
this box is an amino acid that's much
more interesting
that's much more interesting because if
you look at an amino acid and this is an
amino acid
why is an amino acid well it's got an
amine group here and a carboxylic acid
there so it's an amino acid
but see here's the thing r
this is nature's this is nature's the
box
we can put six carbons in we're really
proud of ourselves nature
can put almost anything at once
for r right so r
just to spell this out right so r
is nature's choice
and i'll show you what it chooses
nature's choice
because there are hundreds of amino
acids
um and and the this r
group can do many things um and
but you know just 20 is all we need to
make proteins
most proteins are made out of just
essentially 20.
but if you do the math i think i have
the math here
and you take let's see okay if i take
two amino acids
let's say i take two amino acids so i've
got two different r's
two amino acids and i've got a length
is two and this is called the dipeptide
i'll tell you why in a sec okay but
let's compare this now
now i've got 20 amino acids and i just
told you
that 20 is what nature makes most
proteins out of
20 different r's 20 different there's an
amino acid
r is nature's choice but see if i've got
20
then i've got 20
squared equals 400 dipeptides i've made
a two unit polymer it's not a polymer
it's a peptide
yeah but now what if i take the 20 and
i've got but now i've got
let's say a thousand units long
a thousand units long then i would have
20
to the 1000 possibilities
which is 10 to the 1300
combinations so
10 to the 1300 possibilities
that's because there's a thousand units
and i've got 20 amino acids right it's
just
but now you think how do you how do you
possibly think about what to do
that is nature it's had a billion years
and it's given us the world that we live
in that we know it's
it's it's it's messed with these
combinations
in a way that's impossible for us to
even understand that's why i say nature
is a polymer engineer gone wild
it's got almost limitless flexibility
and it's used it right now how does it
how does nature
make its polymer well it's condensation
polymerization this is the
this is the this is just what we saw
look at that
that's why you have this is what an
amino acid is it's got this carboxylic
so there's the oh group that can
condense with the h here
and form the link there it is that's
called a peptide bond
with two amino acids come together
that's a cn that's a peptide bond
right oh but look this had r1 that had
r2
right and and i've got 20 different
acids amino acids to choose from
the possibilities are endless so the
protein synthesis
is uh
protein synthesis is condensation you
knew that you knew it couldn't be
anything else because there's no double
bond
where would i have done a radical
initiation with these
amino acids if i'm nature i i got to
make it with condensation
polymerization that's how we are made
okay now so you know just to give you a
sense so the r i'm not going to go
through this
obviously i'm just giving this to you as
if you want to read more about it
there's some wonderful charts here 20
amino acids
the 20 that are most common and that
nature puts together
and what they've done that's really nice
here is they've grouped them right
because
what did nature choose to do how
is it most utilizing the properties the
tunability in these amino acids i said
there were 20 but most proteins are
i say there are hundreds but most
proteins are made from these 20 it gives
you the
the tunability in having maybe non-polar
groups
right so it might be then hydrophobic
polar groups
hydrophilic uh maybe you can
you can put nature can put r groups in
there
that have that maybe have a charge or
that lose or take an ion
right so you can it can it can play with
the charge and it has done all of that
it can have groups that become acids
that make something acidic
and so forth okay so that's cool
what has nature done well i i
i gotta show you the spider because um
and if you're interested professor
bueller
does some wonderful work on spider silk
because i think this is a
a great example of something that nature
can do
that that gives us a sense of how far
away we are
like i said we're very proud of this
and we want to do more right
and so we take our two mers and we mix
them together and we make branches maybe
we're going to try to add a third
meanwhile nature has had a lot more
flexibility and a lot more time
what can it do well here's spider silk
now this
is a spider spider is is an incredible
polymer synthesis machine it's an
incredible polymer synthesis machine
and here it is weaving a web and i love
this because i think it's so cool
there's music i guess i forgot about
that and there it is now watch
out of here this is the this is the
front back of the spider there's
there's there it is right there it's
making protein that's called spider silk
right but
these are proteins these are polymers it
is doing
condensation polymerization right there
and then there's
all sorts of structural stuff that it
does right it's got a specialized hook
it knows how to step it creates look at
that there's a branch place where it
knows to put it
right it's already created the glue um
but it and so it not only is it putting
the spider silk out there
but it can put other types of polymer
depending on what it needs does it need
something really sticky less sticky
right and so there it is weaving its web
and it's generating
this polymer on the fly right it's doing
condensation polymerization
now a couple properties about spider
silk okay
so here we go let's see so spider silk
this is this is just one
example of what nature can do it's five
times stronger than steel
remember the chart mechanical strength
chart nothing nothing was stronger than
steel
spider silk is five times stronger just
to give you a sense
the the example i i found that i like if
if um
if you had a spider silk that was a
pencil width and you made a strand it
would stop a boeing 747 in midair
that's how strong it is oh it keeps
keep strengths here's another thing
keeps
strength
below 40 degrees c
we can't do that just take a take a
rubber ball and put it at that low of a
temperature and try to bounce it it's
going to shatter
right no spider cell can keep that
strength and not break
it's elastic so it's got
throughout all of this it's got an
elastic property of
4x so it can be stretched to four times
its original strength
right okay compare that with nitrile
nitrile rubber could also go to very
very high
uh elastic you know elongation right so
if you go back to nitrile right here it
is in the table
we're very happy with this but this only
had two monomers to play with
right we played with two monomers and we
got to here and look at the sacrifice
in the strength look at how much we had
to sacrifice strength
spiders don't have to do that here's the
last one
fully recycles now
the thing is that this is actually
kind of incredible right spider webs get
dusty
spider webs get dusty they lose their
stickiness
so many spiders know this and just
simply
have to weave a new web every day but
they don't leave the old web there they
actually eat it
and they fully recycle it fully
right they eat the web fully recycle it
process it
have this condensation polymerization
work and make a new one the next day
right so we don't
come close to this spider we don't even
come
anywhere near it right in terms of where
we are
even though i gave you all these
wonderful things that we're doing with
engineering
we still have so far that we could go if
we could just figure out how nature
works
okay and this gets me to what we do
and so i've got my why this matters now
and
um so spider eats its web
fully recycles it spins the new web the
next day here's what we do with our
our polymers i already
talked about the oceans um here's what
we do on land
this is a tire these are tires and tires
are very difficult to recycle why
because
you they're they're too vulcanized
they've got too much crosslink remember
if the crosslink density
is too strong which you need to make a
tire
then um then you can't recycle it in
fact what happens is
and here's a there's a tire mound here's
here it is from a satellite picture
those are tires those are tire mounds
here's what happens when one catches
fire here's what happens when many catch
fire
right um it's actually very hard fire to
control
once they catch um and but we don't we
don't really know how to recycle them
well yet what can we do
on the science and engineering side you
know the fact of the matter is
there's a lot of work to do but there
are promising directions so i wanted to
leave you
with a little bit of that and i'm not
going to go into great detail just want
to show you and there's references here
you can look at
this was published a couple years ago in
nature one direction
is in is in self-healing polymers it's a
very exciting direction
what can we do well we can we can go
away from this whole single-use idea and
make stuff last
longer right so that would be beneficial
maybe not if it winds up in the ocean
but in terms of just how
how long we can use these materials um
so one direction is
well you got these these polymer
networks and you incorporate little gels
little beads in here
but the beads don't open up until
a crack comes along so they're sensitive
to a crack and when they feel a crack in
the material
they open up and they pour a healing
liquid
that then solidifies that's a
self-healing kind of approach you can do
that at different scales all the way
down to the strand
you can do that larger scales and here's
a whole system
where there's actually this healing
material being float flowed through a
polymer structure
just like arteries in our body again
always there to try to heal the material
right
another direction is in fully recovering
and
again i don't want to go into full
detail here you can look up some of the
stuff that this was published last year
can we take the polymer and chemically
decompose it all the way back to the
monomer
can we go back to where we started can
we do what the spider does
right the answer is no not today
but if we could that would open up
a whole lot of doors for recycling
that are closed today can we do this in
a way that is efficient
right and and then the another
direction of work that i think is very
important is in making
thermosets so heavily cross-linked so
you get all the hardness and all the
properties you need of the polymer
that's heavily crosslinked but easily
breakable in the crosslink and there is
good work going on
in this direction can we make degradable
thermosets
that's another really important
direction and last
we should be encouraging people if you
can't do any of this at least take the
polymer out of the landfill
and make something with it and there are
projects you can look at here waste
management
journal and in making bricks out of
polymers incorporating them into
construction
materials right these are important
directions and we need a lot more
um hopefully in the very near term
no more just talking about alignment
okay have a good weekend
you